[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ne se passe pas de jours que le sang
ne coule à Chypre les 5000 soldats
britanniques chargés de maintenir
l'ordre sont aujourd'hui incapables
d'éviter ces drames soudains où
s'affrontte Grecs et turc
si de nouveau la violence se déchîne à
chip elle ne reste pas sans écho dans
athèes une manifestation conduite par
des prêtres orthodoxes et des étudiant a
conué l'idée d'une intervention de l'an
mais l'affaire de chipr est sur la voie
de l'internationalisation dans l'île
chaque communauté vit dans la peur de
l'autre et quand les uns après les
autres les villages entiers se replient
comme le village tur d'osos où l' compta
11 morts comment imaginer qu'une
solution intérieure pourra rapprocher
les deux
gros
[Musique]
la Hollande respire bien que 10000
personnes a failli périr étouffé devant
le palais royal où le prince Bernard et
la reine Juliana ramenaient leur fille
Irène et son fiancé le prince HUG de
bourbonpme il n'y a plus de mystère les
cœurs sensibles y ont trouvé leur compte
après 10 jours de suspense qui ont mis
la Hollande au bord d'une crise
constitutionnelle l'amour a donc été le
plus fort et comme l'a dit avec à propos
le Premier ministre néerlandais tout est
bien qui finit bien tout le monde aime
les
[Musique]
amoureux pour la première fois nous
avons pu visiter à ville juif une
réalisation de l'État dans le domaine de
la lutte anti-ancer un institut
dépendant du Centre national de la
recherche scientifique aidé par une
association en faveur du développement
de cette cet institut plus de 300
chercheurs et techniciens travaillent
ici Monsieur Pierre grabard dirige
l'Institut de Recherche scientifique sur
le cancer l'expérience sur l'homme étant
impensable la plupart des études sont
faites sur des animaux mais on sait que
les résultats pourront être appliqués au
cancer humain en liaison avec la
sécurité sociale des études sont
poursuivies sur des prélèvements fournis
par les hôpitaux parisiens dans
l'animalerie 25000 sujets sont
rassemblés des rats souris hamster de
race pur donne plus de garantie aux
expérimentations depuis peu des singes
sont aussi
utilisés voici un appareil permettant
des expériences sur des souris et des
rats de souche pur qui naissent et
vivent en milieu stérile on pourra ainsi
contrôler plus étroitement sur ces
animaux l'apparition des cancers et des
[Musique]
leucémies chaque chef de service va vous
indiquer brièvement l'activité de son
laboratoire en médecine expérimentale
notre activité c'est exerce sur diverses
formes de cancer spontané greffé comme
sur cet œuf de poule
ou encore provoqué par virus radiation
ou corps chimique comme sur ce
rat dans le laboratoire d'études du
tabac nous avons mis au point une
méthode par badigeonage de souris au
goudron de fumée et par examen de la
peau au microscope pour apprécier la
diminution de nosilité des cigarettes
expérimenté par la Régie française des
tabacs le laboratoire de biochimie
analyse les constituants de la cellule
vivante par exemple les acides
nucléiques une modification de leur
structure pourrait expliquer la
cancérisation en virologie on étudie les
virus d'origine humaine et animale
capable de provoquer des tumeurs chez
les animaux et de transformer des
cellules normales en en cellule
cancéreus la connaissance du mécanisme
de telle transformation permettrait de
comprendre le processus de la
cancérisation chez
l'homme la microscopie électronique a
permis des grossissement d'un million de
fois voici la photographie originale
d'un virus cancérigène du singe d'un are
virus qui provient de la souris et voici
la maquette de sa STR moléculaire on a
pu photographier un grand nombre de
virus dans les cancers d'animaux et l'on
essae maintenant de les découvrir chez
l'homme les méthodes immunologiques
permettent de déceler les modifications
des constituants des cellules
cancéreuses on peut ainsi espérer
approcher le problème de la défense
contre le cancer comme on le fait pour
les maladies infectieuses en liaison
avec cet institut h laboratoires sont
dirigés par le professeur Lebreton cette
rap tre la complexité de la recherche
réclamant des équipes de spécialistes
très différents et la part prise par cet
institut au recherches sur le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cancer final au transatlantique de
l'aviatrice française l'atterrissage à
rioano c'est dans son tout petit avion
de 140 chevaux baptis petitouou qu' a
réalisé son exploit solitaire sur la
route de
mer
même à l' de l'IRE interplanétaire c'est
une très grande prouesse qu' réalisé la
ch elle a bien le droit désormais de
goûter les heur de
[Musique]
gloire grand rendez-vous du rugby
international pour le match France all
au St du manoir à colombe dans les
tribunes archom TR spectateurs attentifs
le du de WIS monurm et Monsieur fouch ça
commence bien pour l'équipe de
France match après 4 minutes de je
c'est ensuite une sévère mais correcte
explication d'avant les grands joueurs
noirs des Antipodes nen sont pas encore
revenus les Français font presque jeu
égal avec ce qui les empêche pas
d'égaliser sur coup
Fran ce coup franc va être suivi d'un
essai les All Black ont cette qualité il
ne pardonne aucune faute à leurs
adversaires un mauvais dégagement de
Gachassin et voilà TR points de plus
pour les
néozélanda et pourtant les Français n
font pas beaucoup des fautes dans toutes
les phases du jeu la balle coute
cher mais passionnant le
RBY une poussée comme cela à la mêlée ça
se mesure en tonne de muscles après la
poussée c'est le feu d'artifice des
attaquants français des envoyés de ce
style il y en a eu tout au long de la
deè
mi-temps mais vraiment les Français ont
donné une idée flatteuse de leur rugby
et ça fuse encore le tout petit AER
Gachassin numéro 14 n'a pas peur des
grands ce qui l'empêche pas d'aller au
massacre
les grands maillot noirs d'en face
profitent de tout il ne laissent pas
souffler les Français qui ont les jambes
coupées par un drop de
la la victoire des néozélandais est
incontestable mais un peu sévère pour la
France qui méritait pas d'encaisser un
nouvel essai quoi qu'il en soit dans
tout cela le véritable gagnant c'est le
rugby au jeux
olypie
comme toutes les Françaises elle a été
surclassée dans la dernière épreuve
féminine cependant elle a tout de même
la consolation d'être sacré championne
du monde du combiné la grande
triomphatrice de la descente la voilà
c'est l'Autrichienne crystal
as crystal as ski comme un homme elle en
a le poids et le gabarit bref dans cette
spécialité elle est
imbattable on croyait àin calma
imbattable lui aussi au patinage
artistique le résultat vous le voyez ses
ner ont craqué il a tout
[Musique]
manqué c'est un véritable festival de
chute et ce n'est pas son magnifique
finale qui aurait pu changer quoi que ce
fut au résultat il revient de loin avec
sa médaille d'argent
le vainqueur c'est l'Allemand
schneldorfer il est très appliqué
schneldorfer mais il n'a pas la classe
d'un champion olympique si Alain calma
avait été lui-même il n'y aurait pas eu
de
[Musique]
problème les deux premiers avec la
vedette de demain l'Américain Allen
médaille de bronze en attendant
[Musique]
mieux les skilleurs Français ont imité
leurs compatriotes fémininees eux aussi
ils ont manqué leur sortie pa a beau
gagné avec une facilité dérisoire la
deième manche du slalom spécial il est
trop tard sa chute de la première manche
est impardonnable il est pourtant le
meilleur slalomur mondial dans ces
conditions c'est l'Autrichien pi stigler
sur qui personne ne comptait qui tire
les marrons du feu derrière lui deux
Américains inattendus également William
Kid et Jimmy
[Musique]
Yuga
au grand trempelin une faute a coûté la
médaille d'or au Finlandais Ken il a
complètement manqué son arrivée au
sol ce qui a profité à son vieux rival
norvégien thoralfam champion olympique
[Musique]